[Музика]
- запам'ятовує на твоєму курсі, що
новенька лекція Тубулін і Еліска, безвкусна
модель твоя пенсія, верховний Аллах, я був
кіллакі, так, найбагатший О, уявіть собі,
Шинья, контакт золотистого духу Колорама,
приходять з кожним зі мною, коли вчитель Baja
якого в  ваш дух, що я впевнений, Кулі
і проблема видалення і в'язка
лемархальна час просто переважають
caboose pushover Instagram це і
зарезервована проблема, коли я їм кімчі
не впевнений, що цей замовник мономерний
стіл Rama його щоночі буде екран Vinay
Singh  value
[Музика]
привіт, мене звуть Анна, я
вчитель англійської мови,
і сьогодні ми продовжимо
вивчати англомовні
країни, а також поїдемо до
Великобританії до столиці Лондона,
і ми збираємося переглянути
минулий простий час сьогодні в нашому класі є учні,
тому привіт, привіт
, будь ласка, представтесь, мене
звуть Яна, я знайду іду,
дуже дякую і привіт мене звати Нік і
сьогодні  Я буду хорошим студентом,
це дуже гарне ставлення, тому приємно познайомитися з тобою,
Яна, етнічна, і давайте поїдемо до
Великобританії, тому, оскільки ми сьогодні збираємося до
Великобританії, назвіть речі, які у вас
асоціюються з Лондоном і Великобританією
взагалі, які речі  спадає на вашу
думку, коли ви думаєте про Великобританію,
дощі, дощі, відомий кінорежисер дуже
дешево добре добре, так, які у вас
асоціації з Великобританією Madonna
the Beatles The Beatles Джейсон Стетхем
[Музика]
Majesty Queen так, королева Англії
добре, які види спорту пов’язані  з
Англією, можливо, весело, добре, а тепер
ми зіграємо коротку гру, яка
називається "П'ять", тож тепер ваше завдання -
назвати п'ять англійських футбольних клубів, тож чи
пам'ятаєте ви будь-який Я пам'ятаю Манчестер
Юнайтед
Манчестер Юнайтед добре, так, один з
найбільш  відомі футбольні клуби Яна Я
бачу, що у вас є уявлення
про Ліверпуль
ммм добре Ліверпуль Нік Еліс ви знаєте
Арсенал це правильно,
добре Яна Келсі Челсі так добре добре
дякую і далі  e більше, що це було б
Евертон Евертон Евертон о, це не
дуже відомий
або це дуже відомий право
we'll go gold man said you o no
cheating on English language no googling
okay дякую дуже, так ні 5  - 4
англійські футбольні клуби були
згадані, і ми можемо перейти до решти
нашого уроку, дякую,
але перш ніж ми потрапимо в Лондон, нам потрібно
мати ще одну станцію, ми переглянемо
минуле просто, тому що на попередньому
уроці більше не працює osa move
charlie  довіртеся
монологу в опівночному хопі Торетто. Томо це
Аріс, якого звали Робін, давайте зробимо це,
давайте зробимо це добре, перш ніж перейти до
вправи, я хотів би нагадати вам деякі
дуже важливі речі про
минулий простий час, тому ми зазвичай використовуємо  це для
розмови про минулі закінчені дії можна
побачити використання на дошці найбільш
вибачуваний Ахматова Костова mo na dos semanas нова
особа схвалення Ікара Таня в ньому
описується вже виконана дію
др.  Джіа Яаков каже, що віртуалізований не
рідкий, я їздив до Німеччини минулого року, він
каже, що я академічно деякий з
Маноло, багато я бачу настрої як бунт,
так, де Донна, мій канал:
Маноло Хіроко каже, що незайманий і навіть
завзятий Блазіо Маноло багато чого бачу О  gia
levator / домашній una forma yak my for
Momo retina pass простий нервовий гребінь
Обама картопляна піраміда суб'єкт
Іспаньйола в тюремному документі Prasad
oxidase lava так що це дієслово, і ми
зазвичай маємо другу форму дієслова
в минулому простому реченні або якщо воно є
звичайне дієслово ми просто додаємо закінчення
Edie,
тому, наприклад, я бачив Джейн вчора,
а також неправильне дієслово dr.  Джо Слово бачив
сім, тільки Ісус любив сидіти, але ні,
а пророк на ім'я Ісус laudanum
, щоб раціональні причини почули про
планшети та проблемну леді, яка спала
після Охами попереднього кг Я знайшов Джейн
минулого тижня моя карта Робін Я просто люблю
телефон Маноло дуже  Я сказав, що коли я наблизився
до свого точного в Китаї, Еді Домо затвердила,
що щодо негативних речення, тому,
коли нам потрібно сказати, що щось
не сталося дія макісіма, вона вибрала
Маноло шахту Алісса черниця, що вірш
о, не молись, щоб дозволу  ідея
повільніше, тож яку довідку у слові
ми будемо використовувати тут, чи можете ви поглянути
на дошку і сказати, яке слово допомагає нам
утворювати негатив у минулому простому чи не
[Музика]
Національні ідеї формування. Господь сказав,
що справедливості не може бути  показана окрема
фішка праворуч старший гарно дуже
добре молодець, і тут ми також
маємо слово, яке економісти знають,
які ідеї місії тривають, він подвійно
не знає, хто першим служив Вірджинії,
це перше слово в надісланому  Ні
, не міг би ти
прочитати приклад із дошки, чи бачив ти
Джейн вчора, так, ми починаємо
запитання з did, а потім маємо
дієслово see, чи має форму минулого тут,
щоб просто любити сидіти не  заслуговують аятів,
що Нолан, якого я бачу, Шива ні липня,
це неможливо для мене бути тисненням
до мене в Shamu поговори зі мною, покажи
, ти зробив це не переслідував Пікассо,
слід сказати, що чоловіки тільки груди, якщо це не
буде лави, морський струмінь, так сподіваюся  через
цю назву я маю величезну лаву, вона
може розслаблятися і не має другої форми, тому
вона не використовувалася в минулому, просто якщо ми
це робили, то давайте приступимо до практики, тому,
як ми мудруємо, ага, у
нас є завдання, так, ви повинні
зробіть минуле просте позитивне негативне
або запитання, тож
тут у нас є п’ять речень і
слова в дужках масивний душ
Катя Словаччина я збираюся розібратися з Табітою з Напи,
о, ніхто, що я кажу швидко,
просто, вони можуть мусульманин Амін Амін
з’явився без будь-якого буддиста
планшет, коли  проблемні жінки залишають
чоботи Mousa Avenue, які мають другий Китай IDI
як мінеральні спа-центри, які
можуть пропустити
дані та дані про Leveaux ma nama Trevor Buddha та, тож давайте подивимося на
дошку, і тепер ви збираєтеся відповідати один
за одним добре, так, ви  може почати, дівчата,
спочатку
вона сіла в автобус у центрі
міста
відмінно дуже добре дякую дуже
добре добре наступне речення Нік,
будь ласка, добре, дозвольте мені подумати, о котрій годині
він встав вчора чудово, це
правильно, тому у нас є питання  і
ми матимемо допоміжне дієслово did
перед підметом, а потім ми матимемо
основну форму дієслова to get let's go
to третє речення, тоді ви знаєте, що ваша
черга добре, я спробував, звідки ви взяли
мм-хм з Поїзда дуже добре, так  у
вас вже є ноги, так,
людина, яку я просто люблю мертвого гравця з низів,
Джоанна, бачу, що вони пігментують тебе
слизь, так що базова форма ми її не
змінюємо дуже добре Дякую Нік
номер чотири так, я не змінював
її  Вікторія
так, це правильно, добре, і Яна, остання з
якої ми прокинулися.
друга форма цього,
ми щойно прокинулися, ви все правильно сказали,
дякую, добре, давайте перейдемо до
наступної частини нашого уроку, ось у нас є
малюнки та слова,
тому є чотири картинки, але
трохи більше слів, три слова.  дивно,
тому наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб подивитися на слова та
зіставити їх із зображеннями, але перш ніж ми
почнемо зіставляти
ці слова, нам потрібно переглянути переклад цих слів, поділений
на час, який ви бажаєте Немо, але все ж знаєте,
що словацька мова відбулася в k3 повільних зловісних
символах  Мене блює тісто Hidayah, моя
куртка лава, але виросток це
принаймні елемент вибору,
будь ласка, зверніть увагу, що наближається завіса, тому давайте
почнемо з першого, щоб перетинати те, що
має перетинати перець та інші, але я купив
дуже психотичний мм-хм, гарний вигляд  що таке
погляд  удачі міст Mr.  туман над головою
що голова це правильно не olive oil
tower mr.  Eilert basta basta uh-huh
виставка виставка, це все добре,
і останнє слово тут доріжка
Махапрабху Лемке майже те, що це було
б слово прогулянка, брате, хто Ланка
доріжка
що це так, це розіграш ха о тише Леон
я просто піти,
ти не повинен  Не так, нейрофіброми, брате,
хто живе в цій алаї,
ні, так що тепер давайте порівняємо
слова з картинками, почнемо
з лівого верхнього кута
Лерой Бургнік, ви говорите, то що ми бачимо
на цій виставці в кутку, так це те, що
виставковий підйомник угорі зліва вгорі  виставка,
звичайно, це добре, наступне
зображення нижче
багате, це міст, звичайно, добре,
наступне зображення, що це таке, давайте спробуємо,
я думаю, це шлях,
який пішохідний, звичайно, хороший, і
остання картинка показує нам, так, зараз  як
ви думаєте, що це башта башта добре, тепер
ви освоїли це слово хороша робота,
добре, і тепер ми їдемо в Лондон,
нарешті, ми тут, і ми збираємося
прочитати текст про Тауерський міст,
ви коли-небудь були  до Лондона б  y the way
[Музика]
ні, чи сподобалося б тобі так, що ти
хочеш побачити в Лондоні дуже важливо
Гаррі Поттер є дивовижна
студія Гаррі Поттера мм-хм добре, так, а що
з тобою, що б ти хотів побачити в
Лондоні я бачу  ера скоро ви хотіли б
побачити все, все мм-хм чудово,
тому ми розпочнемо нашу екскурсію
сьогодні з Тауерського мосту, який,
мабуть, є найвідомішим сайтом Лондона,
і зараз ми прочитаємо текст Микита
, будь ласка, почніть читати, прочитайте
текст про Тауерський міст Тауерський міст був
побудований у 1886-1894 роках міст
перетинає річку Темзу він
став знаковим символом Лондона міст
складається з двох веж, пов'язаних
разом, ви можете дізнатися
про найбільші визначні пам'ятки Лондона з
виставки всередині веж та
музей машинного залу дякую, будь ласка,
продовжуйте, ви не бачили Лондона, поки
не побачите панорамні краєвиди з
верхніх доріжок у сувенірному магазині, ви
можете купити різні речі з пакету з картинками
інформаційні буклети до брелока для
майстрів мосту о, добре, добре, велике дякую,
тому Тауерський міст є
конічним символом Лондона та Великобританії,
і ось він, ви можете побачити його на
малюнку, а тепер давайте перевіримо, що ви
запам'ятали з тексту  Тепер завдання полягає в тому,
щоб прочитати речення про Тауерський міст
і визначити, правдиві вони чи
хибні.
Сара генійний текст О, Регіна захищає,
скористайтеся підходом до місії. Атталі в них
тепер прихований стукач навчити навіть рік
проблемі Емма Сільверштейн з
машин Аттики чоловічий текст О, Німеччина ще  ніколи
про Деввармана, якщо вони неправдиві, ваше завдання
полягає в тому, щоб виправити неправильні речення, тому
давайте почнемо з першого,
Яна, будь ласка, міст складається
з трьох мостових веж, це неправда
мм-хм, скільки веж там, тож
ви принесете правильні  речення, тоді
міст складається з двох мостових веж
, це правильно,
дуже добре, дякую Нік, а що щодо
номеру два, ви можете побачити панорамні
краєвиди з
верхнього переробки  транспортний засіб транспортний засіб транспортний засіб, це
правда чи неправда, чи
можете ви побачити панорамні краєвиди з
підвісного транспортного засобу, ви можете побачити
панорамні краєвиди з верхньої
доріжки дивовижно дуже добре, дякую
, перейдемо до номеру три зараз, і Яна
, це ваше речення номер
три, яке ви можете купити  кишеньковий
інформаційний буклет із зображенням у сувенірному магазині,
це правда, це правда. Подивіться, не
хвилюйтеся, це справді добре, і Нік
, будь ласка, прочитайте останню, так,
міст перетинає річку Темзу, це
правда, звичайно, може бути будь-який  інша
річка так, це Лондон, вона стоїть на
річці Темзі,
добре, тому тепер, коли
ми закінчили читати та переглянули попередній
зразок, тепер давайте підведемо підсумок
усього
уроку, ви побачите три
запитання на дошці,
які ви матимете  щоб відповісти зараз, тож давайте
перейдемо туди,
давайте підсумуємо, у нас є три
запитання. Перше, коли був побудований Тауерський міст,
чи пам’ятаєте ви дати розколу
Матата з крапками Coley Bulldogs budova не
Тауерський міст Я думаю, що Тауерський міст
був побудований з 1864 по 1918 рік, і команда і
щось 1894 1894 давайте перевіримо, це
був 1894, ви всі в Європі праві так
1894 це був рік, коли Тауерський міст
нарешті був побудований добре, як я можу назвати
громадськість  виставка творів мистецтва чи предметів, що
представляють інтерес, що проводяться в художній галереї чи
музеї одним словом галерея галерея
ви впевнені,
можливо, ви маєте рацію
past simple давайте
переглянемо давайте пригадаємо, яке слово було
це допоміжне слово, яке допоміжне дієслово зробив
зробив, але щоб скласти заперечне речення,
йому знадобиться тоді not або коротка форма
буде not't didn't не так,
тому що це  добре, якщо у вас немає
запитань, тоді урок закінчено,
дуже дякую, так, і я побачу вас наступного
разу, дякую, дякую,
до побачення
[Музика]
багато залишків конвертів не було знайдено
на Lee school patata вибір
Papa ricordati para  немає книг Лі Упс
не говорив про подвійний ні ніколи не був
Іван ви знаєте, що пріам нижче
мед, пряжа була досить
витончена була Віа Крісті, який
новий Прімо Закат сказав, що Девід повинен мати
приємний смак шоколаду також гепард
Латавія шоколадний лист 11 мільйонів,
хоча  що б вони обрізали ми зробили
міський продукт, атакуючи з наших
шоколадних цукерок, це якби сказали б так, краб
навіть минулої ночі, вана Малуччі в день народження зірок,
ну не сьогодні тут, але не
деякі, щоб подати багато днів позитивну
чоловічу ДНК Івана, ймовірно, водночас
це  гарний міністр, який поки вони не кажуть, що
так, бум, коли куля капча скажи
комунікативному партнеру Ангусу, давай,
коли ти ставишся, Ліза, зроби це Cove
чіп Момо могла б відвідати як ідея перемістити
діаграму рядок будка dimashq на затвердження
фото Рокі багато дат показувати контакт
рішення для розмови складається з
до міста Лондонський міст складається з
двох веж і доріжки
[Музика]
ви